palais de justice de trois ouvertures
d'un procès d'assises
ces hommes et ces femmes sont tous
convoqués pour être jurée dans une
affaire de viol jurés d'assises une
expérience qui marque à tout jamais une
vie je ne suis plus que le furent celles
escomptées et je vous ai plus le nous
c'est un monsieur qui a longtemps tenté
de violer une jeune femme violée oui
mais je crois c'est l'essentiel est
essentielle de l'opposition
voilà quand même un peu ton du thunder
police
travaille à 80 travail ce que ne savent
pas encore ses citoyens ordinaires c'est
qu'ils vont devoir juger un homme qui
clame son innocence
un homme accusé de viol qui reconnaît
avoir eu une relation sexuelle avec une
femme mais qui prétend ne jamais l'avoir
forcée il n'y a aucun témoin aucune
preuve c'est la parole de l'un contre la
parole de l'autre
comment des jurés se forge t-il une
intime conviction lorsqu'ils y a des
doutes sur la culpabilité de l'accusé
nous avons demandé à d'anciens juré de
nous raconter ce qu'ils ont vécu dans le
passé eux aussi ont eu à décider si
l'accusé était coupable d'un viol ou si
au contraire la victime était
consentante
on arrive on a tendance à défendre les
victimes en fer va se placer du côté de
la victime
et on a toujours de l'empathie pour elle
mais il ya aussi après le déroulement de
du procès qui fait qu' il ya des choses
qui arrivent des éléments qui font
réfléchir est assez choqué de voir que
c'était la parole de l'un contre la
parole de l'autre et que à tout moment
ça peut basculer et on peut changer la
vie c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit que
c'est pas tout noir c'est pas tout blanc
qu'il ya un peu de gris et qu'il faut
dix fois me peut composer avec tout ça
c'est dur tout court en fait c'est
surtout au cours de
deux heures voilà c'est un c'est vrai ça
s'est passé ça s'est pas passé alors
personnes aimeraient être à notre notre
place en fait
être juré est un devoir de citoyen
impossible ou presque dix échappés sous
peine d'une amende de 3750 euros chaque
année tirés au sort sur les listes
électorales plus de vingt mille
personnes sont convoquées sur les bancs
d'une cour d'assises
l'homme qui va être jugé aujourd'hui à
troyes va comparaître libre placé sous
contrôle judiciaire il clame son
innocence depuis cinq ans à quelques
minutes de l'ouverture de son procès il
a rendez vous chez son avocat m colomès
bon je vous ai dis aujourd'hui on va
parler de vous je veux personnalités
vers un peu penser à ce que vous alliez
raconter expliquer ouais votre vie
qu'est ce que vous auriez alliés bon ben
là aujourd'hui je veux que le seastar et
se termine je veux retrouver une vie
normale je plus du tout du tout pour
paraître assez distincts gens peuvent
vraiment que ça fait cinq ans cinq ans
que je suis pas cinq ans au site un peu
plus j'y pense en dormant j'y pense en
me levant je pense cependant que tu
prends ma douche pendant que je mange je
pense à tous les moments
cet homme risque 15 ans de prison il
aurait forcé une femme à lui faire une
fellation pénalement il s'agit d'un viol
un crime jugé en cours d'assises
un viol selon la plaignante une jeune
femme de 37 ans un rapport sexuel
consenti selon l'accusé face aux jurés
les deux parties vont devoir s'expliquer
et tenter de les convaincre dans la
salle d'audience m e moser l'avocat de
la plaignante lui donnent ses derniers
conseils
attendez qu'est ce que vous attendez de
ce procès pourrait pour des quoi qu'est
ce que ça implique qu'ils soient
condamnés il fait souvent connu cette
voie la cession de 13 en ce moment c'est
dur franchement vous verrez j'ai plein
de vie de six journées jalce et puis un
soulagement il ya enfin peut pas se
penser à autre chose parce que je veux
vraiment pas être dans la tente comment
vous dites que puisqu'un contre elle
moi je vous considère que le sable fin
de tout le temps même chose c'est
l'impression ressentie c'est bien sûr
mais non il resterait seulement là je
parle en 2010 ca progresse encore oui
mais c'est pas du tout ça non mais c'est
pas ça
c'est l'injure est inquiété par les
jaunes
ces citoyens qui s'apprête à juger pour
la première fois en 48 heures pour
relever un défi à la fois personnel et
collectif
devoir se forger une intime conviction
basé sur les interventions des acteurs
du procès
[Musique]
sofian saboulard et l'avocat général ce
jeune magistrat de 27 ans est sous
pression ils appréhendent ce procès
convaincu de la culpabilité de l'accusé
c'est lui qui a proposé au juge
d'instruction de renvoyer la faire
devant les assises
aujourd'hui ils redoutent un
acquittement
ce sont des fictions par nature il fait
délinquants sexuels compliqué lorsque
l'accusé ne reconnaît pas parce que
c'est des faits où souvent on a pas de
témoin visuel et donc il faut poser le
degré de crédibilité des déclarations la
victime les variations dans les
déclarations du de l'accusé c'est ça qui
emporte la conviction
[Musique]
gilles latapie et président de cour
d'assises depuis plus de dix ans c'est
lui qui va mener les débats bon bah on
va y aller alors
dans la salle d'audience c'est le
premier face à face depuis cinq ans
entre la plaignante et l'accusé
[Musique]
l'audience est ouverte veuillez vous
asseoir s'il vous plaît
bien nous allons donc maintenant
commencer cette audience criminelle
alors monsieur je vais maintenant
procéder au tirage au sort du nom de six
jurés chargés de vous juger et de deux
joueurs supplémentaires
comme dans tout procès d'assises
l'audience commence par un tirage au
sort des jurés parmi les 35 jurés
présents dans la salle 8 seulement si je
rends aux côtés du président seul
l'avocat général et la défense peuvent
s'opposer à la participation de certains
jurés dans ce procès
pour se faire une opinion ils ont le nom
la profession l'âge des jurés et tout se
joue en quelques secondes dans ce genre
d'affaires le choix des jurés reste
déterminant
récuser vous être accusé monsieur paré
défense
juré numéro 10 monsieur francis
accusé d'être récusé monsieur par la
défense
juré numéro 8 madame véronique carré
semblerait que les femmes en tout cas
lorsqu'elles sont tirés au sort et
tendance alors vous savez il faut savoir
se méfier des rumeurs mais en tendance
effectivement à être plus magnanime
vis-à-vis de l'otan à l'auteur d'un viol
qu'un homme juré numéro 15 madame
virginie
entourent m'a appelé j'étais persuadé
d'être récusé au début je pensais pas
que pour les histoires de viols les
jurés avaient été plus dur que les
femmes pour moi c'était évidemment l'
inverse et je me suis j'ai été vraiment
surprise de voir la réaction des hommes
et c'est peut-être après pour ça que
j'ai compris que finalement je n'avais
pas été récusées je pense que les hommes
jurés sont plus intolérant que les
formes je le pense oui non plus
déterminé pour rct catégorique c'était
c'était grave très grave pour nous pour
les femmes aussi mais peut-être qu'elle
réfléchissait plus elle trouvait
peut-être des circonstances atténuantes
alors que les hommes s'étaient vraiment
catégorique
j'aurais numéro 14 monsieur jacky aux
flots
récusé les
décideurs publics en premier
donc c'est pour le ministère public la
population ça parfois plus récuser des
jurés je ne fais pas habituellement
j'estime que souvent on a des
stéréotypes qui sont qui sent qu'ils
sont faux mais comme je sais que j'ai un
avocat en défense qui est offensif je
voulais immédiatement montré que j'étais
là que j'étais présent
oui jurés ont été désignés quatre femmes
et quatre hommes pendant toute la durée
du procès ici je romps à côté du
président et de ses deux assesseurs face
à la plaignante l'accusé et toutes les
personnes qui assistent à l'audience
conserver avant l'ouverture des débats
le juge leur rappelle leur devoir de
jurer de vous rappeler que l'accusé est
présumé innocent que le doute doit lui
profiter de vous décider d'après les
charges et les moyens de défense suivant
votre conscience et votre une conviction
avec l'impartialité la fermeté qui
conviennent un homme probe ray libre et
de conserver le secret des délibérations
même après la cessation de vos fonctions
au début de chaque procès à l'ouverture
des débats le président résume les faits
face à l'accusé et la plaignante les
jurés découvrent la complexité de la
faire
écouter tous âges les récits de tous et
toutes ces choses là c'est ça fait
réfléchir il ya des mots crus il ya eu
des scènes crues et
c'est pas forcément
très agréable à entendre c'est possible
mais ça m'a fait peur parce que fin je
me suis dit oui que ça aurait pu
m'arriver ça aurait pu arriver à
n'importe qui
d'entrée de jeu j'ai toujours eu
l'impression d'être toujours pour la
victime
je me suis jamais posé la question au
début si c'était elle qui mentait ou
l'autre
d'un ton neutre le président énonce les
faits
ce matin de février 2007 la plaignante
par travailler à 5h30 elle croise
l'accusé une connaissance du quartier
ils discutent pendant près de 45 minutes
puis se dirige jusqu'à l'entrée d'un
parking elle le masturber lui fait une
fellation
deux jours après la jeune femme porte
plainte pour viols l'accusé de son côté
répond qu'elle était consentante
première suspension d'audience
l'occasion pour les jurés de se réunir
pour la première fois
bon alors souvent à compter sur
l'impressionnant
qu'est ce qui est impressionnant
c'est impressionnant c'est surtout quand
on voit la cuisine c'est quand même des
grands gaillards quand même quand il est
arrivé derrière moi j'ai dit quelques
loos alors j'imagine un victimes petit
papa un colosse comme ça monde
impressionné déjà
mais surtout qu'il arrivait d'un seul
coup je ne vais pas ça va être le
rapport entre la parole de l'un et la
parole de l'autre justement savoir
lequel dit la vérité s'ils en profitent
pas pour
ce seront les débats qui vont nous le
dire par la suite
un viol et des meurtres ou pas comment
j'ai fait beaucoup de viol il ya des
meurtres sans le temps d'une petite
villa est d'accord mais voyons d'abord
il y en a aussi mais même journal on
voit pas tant que ça non mais vous avez
raison le quotidien de cour d'assises
c'est quand même déjà au moins
70 % c'est des faits de nature sexuelle
comme ça c'est l'argent
c'est un crime ce qu'on a le plus
fréquemment ses bras le jeune
maître colomès l'avocat de la défense
profite pour sa part de cette suspension
pour donner quelques consignes à son
client vous êtes le plus naturel
possible ça c'est vraiment une fonction
si la fin de la matinée on pourrait vous
faire inviter non c'est trop tôt ce soir
on y verra déjà plus que
clairement dans votre dossier toile est
essentiel on n'est pas là pour noyer le
poisson reçu 1 on est là pour dire les
choses telles qu'elles se sont déroulées
comme vous l'avez dit qu il était en
garde à vue la première chose que vous
dites veut on que dit elle vous reproche
ce si vous dites oui j'ai une relation
savent pas que sait-il pas s'il peut dit
j'ai une relation sexuelle avec cette
fille je dire voilà vous n'êtes pas dans
une situation où pendant des heures
voire des jours vous dit non il s'est
rien passé pas du tout je la connais pas
je n'ai jamais vu où on a simplement
discuter vous dit j'ai une relation
sexuelle avec cette fille point bas ben
voilà on va à l'essentiel
[Musique]
bon on va y retourner
d'accord
[Musique]
dans cette affaire pas de preuve pas de
témoin visuel une difficulté de plus
pour l'avocat général qui vise la
condamnation d'un accusé qui comparaît
libre je comprends que dans l'esprit
d'un juré le fait de voir un homme libre
se présente est libre une cour d'assises
peut avoir une incidence lorsque vous
comparez ces détenus pour injure et il
ya peut-être dans l'esprit une
problématique de près peine donc il est
plus difficile pour le magistrat du
parquet de convaincre de la culpabilité
d'un homme qui comparaît libre
allez on y va
[Musique]
le président appelle maintenant l'accusé
à la barre pour lui poser des questions
sur sa vie sur sa personnalité un
premier face à face des jurés avec
l'accusé
j'ai eu peur parce que on est
on est face à face donc
montre donc en tant que juré
on est on est pas là un visage caché
donc on peut nous voir la famille peut
nous voir aussi et on peut effectivement
penser qu' on peut être victime aussi de
représailles on sait
me cissé c'est rare mais ça peut arriver
devant les assises de 3 le jeune homme
répond clairement à tout ce qu'on lui
demande il raconte qu'il est issu d'une
famille nombreuse et aimante à 25 ans il
vit encore chez sa mère et enchaîne les
petits boulots
la plaignante l'accusé explique qu'il la
connaît de vue et précise qu'il y a
toujours eu un jeu de séduction entre
eux ils ne comprends vraiment pas ce
qu'il fait dans cette salle d'audience
[Musique]
on ne peut
pas
sortir un petit peu d'accord un bon un
petit café
c'est un moment difficile pour votre
client très difficile à nathan les plus
intenses procès donc c'est une langue
très très longue attente avec un
parcours du combattant pour les victimes
quoi pendant des années ça s'améliore
mais pour elle fait très difficile et là
le fait de le revoir c'est la première
fois qu'elle le rejoigne donc la cdpa le
regarder mais l'entendre il y là et pour
elle c'est toutes les émotions qu'ils
reviennent mais c'est très difficile
pour elle
bien bien lors d'un coup de grand
silence s'est instauré à des voix
s'exprimer quoi c'est
on en prend plein la vue qu'on un seul
khune à bout
c'est ça fait bizarre et puis monde
c'est vrai qu'il emmène paloma et 7 se
défendre comme il peut
faurecia ben voilà bien sûr
fait ce qu'il peut avec ses mots
on sait bien que ce n'est pas facile de
la phase 2 de neutre
de notre assemblée là c'est très
impressionnant un coin du monde c'est un
chèque de 6 en tout cas beaucoup
d'émotion les deux côtés d'ailleurs
parce que pour ces très graves aussi
d'être accusés comme ça et c'est c'est
très difficile de venir et donc d'être
obligé de parler de choses extrêmement
quand même personnel parce qu'il aura
après on va entendre là maintenant la
reprise aussi l'entendre cette dame
puisque on n'a pas encore entendu le son
de sa voix pour
et ça c'est super d'être difficile parce
que vous voyez déjà se mettre déjà
extrêmement 50 ans s'est tendu à le
regarder elle est maintenant je sens
qu'elle est
dans une situation très très délicate
voilà cette rixe est cette personne
[Musique]
je pense que le fait qu'elle la tête
baissée en permanence qu'elle ait
beaucoup de mal à affronter le regard de
toutes façons de l'auteur peut des fois
être mal interprété et pourrait
peut-être être mal vécue par les jurés
mal interprété et ne pas la servir
maintenant elle est comme ça
[Musique]
alors l'audience et reprise veuillez
vous asseoir s'il vous plaît
c'est au tour de la jeune femme de venir
témoigner à la barre elle aussi revient
sur sa vie et finit par sa version des
faits le viol qu'elle dit avoir subi
ça on ne vit pas il pas spécialement
bien un penseur nous pensons surtout à
elle qui a déjà été traumatisée une fois
et qui ont encore aujourd'hui on remet
ça sur le devant tout le monde quoi ça
fait
parce qu'il y avait quand même du monde
et ça c'est ça doit pas être facile à
vivre pour elle et c'est pas facile à
vivre pour nous non plus ça c'est pas le
c'est pas le meilleur souvenir je trouve
ça très courageux de
de supporter
supporter un procès pour viol surtout de
le revivre et puis de dead juger parce
que finalement ils seront jugés puisque
on sait pas on se pose des questions et
forcément on va regarder les deux et on
va se poser des questions sur elle comme
sur l'autre mais ce qui est important
c'est d'entendre sa version
après que je sois convaincu ou pas ça
c'est un la conviction se fait pas dès
les premières paroles
[Musique]
devant les jurés la plaignante se
dévoile une mère maltraitante une
adolescence douloureuse d ancien
compagnon violent elle confie avoir eu
du mal à prendre sa vie en main puis
fébrile cette mère de quatre enfants
raconte en larmes ce qu'il s'est passé
selon elle ce matin de février 2007 à
5h30 en partant au travail elle croise
l'accusé qui durant 45 minutes
alcoolisées les yeux exorbités tient des
propos obscènes et la menace il exerce
un chantage affirme que si elle refuse
de lui faire une fellation il irait cole
porter à son mari les pieds rumeurs
l'accusé l'emmène alors jusqu'à l'entrée
d'un parking souterrain en la tenant par
le coup tétanisés par la peur elle dit
avoir été incapable de réagir
[Musique]
et une une tension parce que les jurés
sont parfaitement conscients très
rapidement qu'il se trouve en face de
deux paroles qui sont totalement opposés
et qu' ils comprennent bien que nous
allons avoir une décision à prendre
on a cette fois su leur cours un
accord
politique des petits pas d'accord non il
ya des impressions qui sont donnés deux
par telos on va en parler on va en
discuter
c'est ça dure deux jours un
hockey
[Musique]
13 heures pause déjeuner
à 50 mètres du palais la plaignante a
trouvé refuge dans une brasserie
submergée par la honte elle n'a pas
souhaité que son mari la compagnie au
procès son seul soutien c'est karen sa
meilleure amie ça seul confident qui est
à ses côtés depuis cinq ans pour
convoyer autant de filles qui font pas
peur pourquoi y en a
du coup elle abandonne à mon avis il
faut prouver tellement que tu l'a pas
choisi
je n'en retiens ce jeudi je vais être
reconnu comme stature si vous changez
pas fait ça pour l'argent ça fout la
trouille pour sa soirée porter plainte
alors c'est le début d'un truc c'est
xavi 28 ans
on peut gérer ce type cdd à la france
s'est retrouvée là tout peut arriver
parce que oui ça peut arriver qu'on le
reconnaisse pas aucune ne sera pas là si
c'était le toit se sera pas la fin du
monde me demande c'est fini
[Applaudissements]
14h15 retour au palais de justice
dans la salle d'audience l'accusé seul
attend la reprise des débats
le coeur y baa3 soit leur passé pour
deux mois ça se trouve je suis seule
barre où ses impôts et c'est difficile à
vivre
[Musique]
l'audience est reprise mais les musées
sport s'il vous plaît
l'avocat général a convoqué des témoins
pour l'accusé et pour la plaignante les
témoins favorables à la jeune femme
décrivent une femme courageuse honnête
et travailleuse
puis c'est au tour d'audrey une jeune
femme de 30 ans
la voix tremblante elle affirme elle
aussi avoir été victimes de l'accusé il
y à plus de 5 ans elle aurait subi des
attouchements il l'aurait harcelée lui
aurait fait du chantage pour lui
caresser les seins je pense que cette
audition de cette seconde victime a pu
appui en tout cas déstabiliser m colomès
et participer à l'accusation mais ça on
verra demain soir
avant qu audrey nos parts maître mot
sert l'avocate de la partie civile
décide d'expliquer à cette jeune femme
qu'elle peut donner plus de force à sa
parole de victimes vous lui si vous
souhaitez
ne pas être simplement des monts et vous
constituer partie civile vous avez la
possibilité
ça veut dire qu'on reconnaît vraiment
officiellement le statut de victime donc
si vous lui en voulez toujours si il
faut le faire d'accord c'est important
vous êtes une victime en plus près par
n'y a pas qu'une victime est absurde
aussi à votre place je le ferai parce
que c'est important pour vous je pense
aussi psychologiquement vous soyez aussi
pas que témoin dans cette affaire
aujourd'hui puisque il est convoqué
aujourd'hui aussi pour vous pour être
condamné pour ce qui vous a fait
[Musique]
audrey décide de se constituer partie
civile ce qui lui permet de s'associer à
l'accusation pour la défense c'est un
coup dur
monde
j'ai du mal à concevoir ce soit quelque
chose de spontané quelqu'un qui est le
témoin qui se constitue partie civile
comme ça après cinq ans brutalement on
est devant ses juges et
j'ai du mal à ne pas concevoir que la
personne en se constituant partie civile
ne viennent pas non seulement pour qu'on
lui reconnaisse le statut de victime
mais peut-être et avant tout pour aller
et venir c'est quémander quelques
dommages et intérêts voilà c'est comme
ça que je le perçois de leur côté les
jurés s'interroge sur l'attitude des
deux jeunes femmes ne serait-ce que
leurs positions physiques
défensivement et très
comment dire comme si l on vous avez
tout le poids de fin du monde quand je
reviens de la ligue 2 la mise en vente
sur les éboulements même à se demander
si la deuxième personne en fait à la
presse suivi plus quoi on est à l'état
de psychologie qu'elle avait
demandés vraiment signer c est la veille
à l'épaule l'autre chose c'est à cacher
pas quelque chose quoi
sous pression après ce témoignage
l'accusé est à bout
ça mais c'est mon envie de craquer même
devant la cour d'assises on va pas vous
reprocher
ok d'accord
on se rend compte du tout j'ai dit la
vérité ça fait cinq ans que je me sens
pas bien du tout façon c'est quand vous
attendez cinq en cinq ans pour savoir ce
qui va se passer mais pour vous sentir
bien j'ai encore pu vous faut laisser
faire le cours de choses maintenant ok
je pense que j'espère ou
de façon demain quels qu'ils soient
entendus parce que pour l'instant elle
met à parler de sa vie ce matin il n'a
pas encore évoqué les faits voire qui
s'explique quand même 1
et 2%
mesdames et messieurs alors que voilà de
bonnes bonnes soirées bon retour et
cette attention sur les routes
[Musique]
ce sont des gens qui sortent de la vie
réelle lundi matin ils étaient encore
avec leurs illusions et puis brutalement
ils sont plongés dans
un monde qui leur est étranger qui ne
connaissent pas et c'est une plongée
en apnée ils n'ont pas le temps de
respirer
extrêmement brutale ça moi j'en suis
parfaitement conscient
j'étais assez stressé le soir en
rentrant surtout que ça se finisse et
tard ça reprenait tôt et on y pense on y
réfléchit on veut pas se tromper donc
c'est vrai qu' on n'est pas on n'est pas
serein
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]
8 heures du matin cette journée est
déterminante pour m colomès ce soir les
jurés vont prendre leur décision
condamner ou acquitter son client
convaincu de sa bonne foi m colomès se
rend sur les lieux où les faits se sont
déroulés il ya cinq ans son objectif
essayer de comprendre ce qu'il s'est
passé pendant une heure entre son client
et la plaignante voilà le lieu où les
faits se seraient déroulés
entre
l essentiel et à son travail mais
finalement apparemment il n'y a pas
d'urgence il ya pas de précipitation et
bien au contraire et bien le par le
dialogue
et pour lui il le perçoit probablement
comme un début de séduction il a peu ou
pas de relations avec les femmes il se
passe quelque chose dans sa tête j'ai du
mal à penser que en partant de ce jeu de
la séduction
soudainement brutalement on passe à un
jeu plus violents elle a la possibilité
de partir à tout moment elle va
travailler et je veux dire voilà quel
est le poids de la contrainte à ce
moment là est ce qu'il ya eu seulement
contrainte mais quel est le poids la
contrainte à supposer que cette
contrainte soit établie
l'avocat n'hésite pas à avancer une
autre hypothèse une hypothèse qui
remettent en cause la bonne foi de la
jeune femme et si c'était tout
simplement la culpabilité tout
simplement la culpabilité d'une femme
qui a eu une relation sexuelle avec un
homme librement consentis il vit sous la
dépendance de son mari et qui n'ose pas
lui avouer et qui va être chargé toute
la journée de culpabilité au point de se
dire je vais transformer travestir cette
histoire banale et peu romantique en
quelque chose de beaucoup plus sordides
encore
et peu importe si je doit sacrifier
quelqu'un
[Musique]
pour ce dernier jour du procès l'escorté
policière se met en place au palais de
justice en cas de condamnation l'accusé
devra être transféré immédiatement à la
maison d'arrêt
ont retrouvé un de 25 ans est accusé
d'avoir violé à trois une jeune femme
alors qu'elle a travaillé à pied verdict
ce soir
les actes et nous ce que vous avez dit
ça quand ils vous abordent ils vous
parlent si ton de votre compagne qui
vous menace qui vous tient des propos
gérer à nîmes et obscène
d'énergie et les chiffres sont
difficiles
[Musique]
c'est vrai la tv où
on sait pas que c'est vous
je crois que c'est ce qu'ils abaissent
le plus elle pensait pas qu'on sera
obligé d'étaler toute sa vie comme ça
pour une heure et demie de sa vie à 5h30
le matin a l'impression que c'est elle
qu'on juge une façon pour les victimes
de viol c'est toujours comme ça je veux
dire il faut qu'elle justifie de son
truc quoi et ça ne comprends pas elle
comprend pad est obligé de se justifier
à longueur de temps pour dire non c'est
bien arriver quoi de son côté m colomès
a tenu à voir son client dans son bureau
avant la reprise des débats
[Musique]
pour vous j'ai prévu d'aller problème
pour nous vous
le garder dans un coin quand même de
votre tête il faut savoir envisager les
choses il faut savoir envisager le pire
d'accord
n'ont pas
fait pas fuir non ok
vous vous exprimez comment vous exprimer
exprimer hier la même façon
[Musique]
toujours et encore bonjour
alors
wire soir qui moi c'est très violent est
visée on va jeter vidéo je sais c'est
dur avec ce qu'on entend la honte en
lacets oui c'est vrai mais je suis moi
je trouve que dans le journal que je
trouve qu'ils prennent parti
après dans ma maison patronne watts ça
fait quand même une bonne expérience
parce qu'on lit un journal on a pas mais
bon une opinion et là on est sur le
vraiment sur le terrain elle est une
autre une éventuellement ou who goes non
enfin louis nicollin diront l'autre mais
tout dire on en connaît tous les faits
on est resté à tous les dossiers je
pense à vue quand tu lis le journal
après tu vas dire mais il apprit que ça
puisqu'il est dit oui oui mais voilà
c'est vraiment être dans le
[Musique]
c'est la reprise il va falloir muscler
son jeu voilà c'est le terminal falloir
passer à l'offensive si on voit une
chance de démontrer ce que je vais
démontrer en l'occurrence et culpabilité
voilà je crois qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'experts qui vont être entendus
et les expertises sont déterminantes
dans dans ce dossier voilà là on a un
regard objectif experts ça c'est
déterminant
[Musique]
les experts psychiatres et psychologues
se succèdent pour décrire les
personnalités de la plaignante et de
l'accusé dans un procès pour viol sans
preuves médicales sans témoin visuel
l'audition de ces experts peut être
déterminante pour des jurés qui doivent
se forger une intime conviction
lors les experts et un est très
important a dit l'essentiel même il faut
bien sûr il faut bien se raccrocher à
quelque chose parce que puisque à chaque
fois c'est bon c'est pas vrai s'est
parlé elle était consentante
pas prendre
un viol mais au moins juste avoir une
idée de la personnalité de l'accusé ça
peut expliquer certains comportements
les experts décrivent l'accusé comme un
être froid et immature qui n'a pas
conscience des choses
concernant la plaignante les experts la
présente comme une femme craintive ayant
subi un traumatisme pouvant peut-être
résulter d'un viol moi je dirais que le
plus important dans les témoignages ce
sont les experts parce qu'ils ont quand
même le côté professionnel
la crédibilité liées à leur profession
jeudi ram 6 4 est un médecin à la base
quand même j'aurais presque une autre
analyse j'ai le sentiment que dans le
monde judiciaire actuelle
on a tendance à considérer que la parole
des experts est une parole d'or qu'elle
est et elle doit être suivie quoi qu'il
arrive
j'ai de sérieux doutes moi je pars du
principe que
confier la justice à des experts se peut
s'avérer parfois extrêmement dangereux
ce que vous en avez pensé de ces deux
experts qui sont venus
le premier j'ai un peu compliqué compris
puisqu'il parlait normalement avec
chrome os enfin les moules à tous les
jours le deuxième un petit peu moins
quand on verra ce qu il parlait il avait
ses propos face aux propos d'experts
vous vous avez l'habitude donc nous un
petit peu compétents qui connaissent
bien la page insuffisamment à votre ado
tu niveau qu'aujourd'hui au niveau par
rapport au vocabulaire est ce qu'on peut
entendre l'accusé
mais comment le danton une première fois
mais là on va l'entendre effectivement
va l'entendre sur les faits parce que là
il n'a pas pu s'expliquer pour l'instant
complètement il s'est expliqué sur sur
des points sur un certain nombre de
points mais pas sûr
pas sur les faits de même
ce que vous allez dire sur
sur ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce que
vous allez dire précisément par rapport
à voile à rentrer le moment où les ide
bon jour elle est d'accord avec ça
maintenant que qui se passe justement
par les eaux je vous dis plus à l'aise
qu'elle faisait que l'on tient des
morceaux petits comme des grands
jusqu'à maintenant la rue est ensuite
c'est en y entraînant
rapport de drague ensuite je demande est
suivi avec son consentement et sans
aucune sanction
la température c'est vous qui la faute
d'accord
[Musique]
le premier le temps
vous avez toutes vos valeurs ok bien sûr
vous suivez pas les questions
au nom même si son candidat on répondra
pas quoi
et quand on sait pas on sait pas on
invente pas des histoires
d'accord c'est pas ça je dis soyez vous
c'est
vous qui fait la job la spa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
le régime s'est reprise veillée vous
asseoir sur beaucoup
l'accusé est le dernier à être entendu
par la cour sur les faits au début du
procès avons avant tout question
toute explication forcément j'étais pour
la victime après c'est sûr qu'on se pose
un peu des questions on revient un peu
en arrière on hésite beaucoup et c'est
vrai qu'on a besoin d'avoir tout
d'avoir vécu tout le procès pour
vraiment se faire une opinion
on change souvent d'avis et bizarrement
pas dans le sens qu'on pense
l'accusé explique qu'il connaît la jeune
femme depuis longtemps il parle de
sourires et de regards échangés
lorsqu'ils se croisent est le début
d'une idylle le matin des faits il la
rencontre en sortant d'un bar ils
discutent amicalement comme à leur
habitude elle se confie sur ses déboires
conjugaux il la réconforte et puis les
choses se seraient fait naturellement
l'avocat général sort alors de ses gonds
essaie de le pousser dans ses
retranchements
selon lui la discussion entre l'accusé
la plaignante n'était pas une discussion
amicale en et soins de contraintes
morales avec une victime qui a une
fragilité structurelle et mon travail
est de montrer que l'accusé connaissait
cette fragilité et qu'il a
instrumentalisé
face aux jurés l'accusée ne se laisse
pas déstabiliser
il explique qu'il aurait proposé un
rapport sexuel à la jeune femme elle n'a
pas dit non elle ne l'a pas repoussé
pour lui elle était consentante
[Musique]
vous m'avez impressionné
mais bon
c vous êtes
largement au dessus hu
il a longtemps
demandé d'aller travailler tu
sais pas ce qu'on va faire sourire à
quelqu'un qu'on va tout de suite arrivé
à la drague gay quoi je dirais à 5h30 je
demandais rien chantelle chez moi j'ai
juste me rendre à mon travail j'ai
jamais demandé de faire une fellation
quoi que ce soit personne quoi
au bout
c'est là pour vous
c'est pas maintenant qu'ils ont flanché
du machin
sa faculté plus ça va
arriver les mains dans les poches mais
ça allait super tranquille et sans bien
cette île et puis si tranquille que ça
là il sent que ce soir
s'est tenu
sa deuxième chance pour
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est cette fois
monsieur étasunien très agressif ce
matin
il est compétent il est clair mais il
est trop agressif
ça et une certaine nervosité qui
s'installe du côté de la ministère
public est plutôt pas mal ça
aucune preuve sur le pire c'était aucune
preuve parce qu'on vous montre aux
mèches dans un système à l'américaine
d'accord oui bien vous rappelle voilà on
n'est pas dans un système où on
n'échange pas tout contrôler oui on est
dans un système à la française un
système latin voilà on va chercher si je
viens à l'intérieur des juristes leur
intime conviction ce qu'ils pensent
vous voulez me
suis
justement
ça se voit
tu sais ce que c'est
oui ça débarrasse
d
l'avocate de la partie civile et la
première a plaidé maître mot sert veut
faire comprendre aux jurés pourquoi sa
cliente ne s'est pas défendu pourquoi
elle ne s'est pas enfui pourquoi elle
n'a pas dit non elle explique que cette
jeune femme maltraitée dans son enfance
battu par ses anciens compagnons étaient
en état de choc face à cet homme très
imposant qui la menaçait apeurée
traumatisée elle a cédé sous la
contrainte en aucun cas il ne s'agit
d'une relation consentie mais bien d'un
viol
bon le port de retard en photo
hockey
mineur écart de cause
[Musique]
1h15 de pause déjeuner une pause
précieuse pour l'avocat général et
l'avocat de la défense qui doivent
ajuster leurs plaidoiries ils jouent
leur dernière carte dans ce procès
catlin qui s'exprime bien comme si leur
il était dans la peau d'un personnage
très torturée par son physique par son
passé par la mort de son père sait pas
faire avec les femmes et maladroit c'est
un gros patapouf à une femme qui
rencontre au petit matin et qui lui dit
qu'elle a pas une vieux rose évalue
problème de rvi est la peur je conçois
qu'elle ait peur elle le connaît un peu
steeple la vue et virtuose la vie qui
propose va acheter je pense qu'il est
sincère quand tu ne le propose je crois
qu'il le pense à elle n'accompagne cette
peur est là verbalisera aucun moment
elle exprimera aucun moment là toute la
problématique
maintenant qu'est-ce que les jurés
peuvent tirer tout ça
cette posture qui consiste à essayer de
décrédibiliser les victimes
allant même jusqu à les disqualifier et
a tenté de les rendre responsables de ce
qu'ils ont subi
à quitter sa maison serait
inévitablement au vu de sa personnalité
lui délivrer pour le futur un permis de
violer
s'il vous plaît faites votre maximum m
retour de l'accusé au tribunal pour les
dernières heures de son procès
est toujours d'accord déploiement
très bien de leur comportement elles
pénètrent possible qu'au moment jouer
plus
oui et
[Musique]
un l'audience surprise vos espoirs et
vos coups
l'avocat général explique l'accusé ne
fera pas au hasard qui choisit ses
proies des femmes fragile incapable de
lui résister l'accusé à profiter de
leurs faiblesses pour assouvir ses
fantasmes
si les victimes n'ont pas dit non c'est
qu'elle était en état de sidération
l'accusé laisse deux femmes traumatisées
condamné à vivre avec ce sentiment de
honte de culpabilité toute leur vie il
requiert six ans de prison
[Musique]
a expliqué un des jurés une victime peut
rester une heure sidéré parce qu'elle a
peur parce qu elle est terrorisée c'est
difficile et ça ouvre naturellement la
voie à la défense
[Musique]
toute personne a droit à être défendu
mais c'est pas facile non plus on sent
bien qu'il faut qu'ils défendent
l'accusé
nombreux témoins brooks et j'ai trouvé
un petit peu rocambolesque à certains
moments
effectivement ils font peur c'est du
théâtre c'est un peu de mise en scène
à cet instant l'objectif de m colomès et
d'installer le doute dans la tête des
jurés et de la cour
selon lui son client n'a pas eu la
sensation de commettre un viol puisque
la plaignante ne l'a pas repousser s est
laissé faire il a mal interprété le
comportement de la jeune femme qui ne
s'est pas défendu
m colomès demande l'acquittement de son
client
exclusif des bonnes choses ce que j'ai
fait les bonnes choses à ce que j'ai agi
est-ce que j'ai été entendu jeudi pas
compris leur demande pas tant mais au
moins entendu
est ce que j'ai pu justement créé cet
échange avec les jurés voilà c'est la
vraie question qui se pose sur le moment
les débats sont clos et dams et
messieurs les jurés nous allons
maintenant nous rendre dans la chambre
du conseil pour délibérer nous ne
pourrons sortir qu'après avoir pris
notre décision audience criminelle est
suspendu mesdames et messieurs les jurés
veiller sur les couilles au moment où le
président met en place ce délibéré on
sent qu'immédiatement par rapport aux
plaidoiries il suffit de quelques
secondes mais au bout de quelques
secondes ils sont déjà dans un autre
monde voilà s'ils sont absents voilà ils
sont déjà partis délibérer
le délibéré est secret
les jurés sont enfermés dans une salle à
l'abri de tous les regards ils vont
débattre avant de devoir répondre à deux
questions en leur intime conviction
l'accusé est il coupable si oui quelle
sera la peine
ce sens avant les seuls comme tombante
c'est
parce que je le vaux c'est nous qui
sommes au point et c'est pas c'est pas
aussi simple que ça dur de juger
quelqu'un j'ai des filles
c'est très compliqué le plus dur c'est
de pas voilà c'est de déterminer si oui
ou non la personne est coupable des
faits qui lui sont reprochés
[Musique]
je pense que c'est très discuté ça
l'était au tout début de l'audience et
ça l'est encore plus maintenant voilà
donc je ne sais pas quelle sera la
teneur de ce délibéré je suis pas
totalement optimiste 1 je vous cache pas
mais oui je pense qu'ils m'ont à l'issue
des réquisitions il s'en dit il ya quand
même des éléments gamme les éléments
pour entrer en voie de condamnation et à
l'issue de la plaidoirie en défense ils
ont dit oui et quand même un peu de
doute voilà quel était l'état d'esprit à
mon avis au delà de la cour d'assises et
c'est pour ça que je pense le délibéré
va durer un certain nombre de temps
derrière cette porte gardée par un
policier les jurés tiennent entre leurs
mains l'avenir d'une femme et d'un homme
[Musique]
j'peux plus j'veux
voeux à la presse en france bat parce
que moi je remuerai et ça c'est dur
c'est pour aller dire que tout à l'heure
s'il est déclaré non
ça tu pourras les tenants ça tu pourras
dire que j'avais mon couple à ce jeu car
elle je vois ici je peux faire appel du
suprême jeu lâchera pas la faire tu
croyais qu'il allait à vous parce que ne
se parlaient pas y croire jamais ça sera
arriver n'importe quel con il va pas
dire oui c'est moi il risque six ans de
prison les ailes il va pas dire oui je
les fais non banon le fait que tu n'es
pas dit non pour lui ça veut dire oui
lui quand il parle là il se croit
crédible
c'est ça la mythomanie et maintenant il
faut attendre qu'ils délibèrent
[Musique]
moi
j'espère qu'il s'en trouve pas en deux
manches et j'ai beaucoup pas trop je
pense qu'il faut reconnaître les fonds
et je vais manger honnêtement je pense
je peux aller en prison peut-être 20
minutes
métro moderne la cour a délibéré ça il
ya une commande pour arriver merci
le délibéré a duré deux heures les
parties doivent rejoindre la salle
d'audience pour l'énoncé du verdict
c'est pas dit qu'on ait emporté la
conviction de trois magistrats
professionnels seraient donc
l'appréciable
[Musique]
eux seuls connaissent la décision quand
on est sûr voilà la culpabilité oui non
là le moment où il rentre là c'est
toujours intense en émotions
tout de suite on voit quand il rentre en
voir les comportements il ya d'abord la
façon de marcher
tête de hutus tête basse
je vois des fois revenir et avoir une
tête baissée alors est ce que c'est
parce que il ya ce poids de jugement qui
viennent de rands de se dire voilà parce
que là est ce qu'ils pensent encore est
ce que la décision j'ai prise est la
bonne il y à la façon de regarder ou de
ne pas regarder voilà quand ça c'est
peut-être l'aspect le plus important
quand vous voyez que ils font tout pour
ne pas vous voir pour ne pas vous
regardez c'est que c'est pas très bon
bien alors levé vous s'il vous plaît
alors voici la réponse aux questions
posées l'arrêt délibéré en commun la aux
questions posées à la cour et aux jurés
leur réponse est oui la majorité de six
mois au moins en répondant oui les jurés
ont reconnu l'accusé coupable la cour et
le jury réunit
après en avoir délibéré ensemble et voté
conformément à la loi par décision
acquise à la majorité absolue
condamne saint mirren la peine de six
ans d'emprisonnement
disposez maintenant d'un délai de dix
jours pour faire appel de cette décision
passé ce délai vous n'y soyez plus
recevables ou dix ans criminels élevé
les jurés ont suivi le réquisitoire de
l'avocat général
il condamne l'accusé à six ans de prison
et à 15000 euros de dommages et intérêts
qu'il devra verser à la victime
un coin
lorsque des bénéfices team qui se
retourne vers ou qui vous dit merci
voilà on sait pourquoi on fait ce qu'on
fait ce métier donc
je me satisfais pas de priver de sa
liberté
le condamné mais choisir de voir une
victime qui a été reconnue dans sa
souffrance et de voir qu'on a été suivi
dans ses réquisitions
c'est un soulagement quand on sait que
le dossier a été âprement débattus
parce que je parte event en détention
que j'ai un temps de préparation
vous partez tout de suite c'est la
savane à lui parler je vous avais
prévenu je vous avais dit si vous partez
en détention vous partez ce soir
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
maintenant ça signifie clairement vous
pouvez libéré au bout de trois ans
[Applaudissements]
thomas cap est risqué
[Musique]
notre chance est quelque chose qui régit
jugé coupable le condamné ne fera pas
appel le jugement est donc définitif
deux jours de procès d'assises deux
jours qui ont fait basculer le destin
d'une femme et d'un homme
[Musique]
pour les jurés c'est maintenant le
moment de se séparer
chacun va reprendre le cours de sa vie
mais la plupart de ses citoyens
ordinaires n'oublieront jamais cette
expérience
avant d'être juré on était une personne
et je pense qu'une fois qu'on a on a
vécu cette expérience on voit les choses
différemment on peut pas rester
insensible par rapport à tout ça c'est
pas possible
et où on a on envoyait des personnes en
prison est un oui ça change des choses
c'est toujours présent c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut pas oublier
[Musique]
pour